There are so many new beauty products
being released all the time,
so we gathered some of the most hyped
from the last month to test for ourselves.
First up, we have the Fenty Beauty
Bright Fix Eye Brightener Concealer.
I feel like I was confused
as to what this actually was,
because the shade range actually had
normal concealer shades
and what I would consider
more corrector shades.
So I went with the peach one to use
as a corrector/brightener
under my concealer.
I guess it's supposed to conceal
and brighten and correct.
I did like the brightening
effect with this,
although it is more subtle.
I feel like it's super
lightweight and blendable.
It's not a thick consistency at all,
so you can layer it up if you want.
That's what I tried to do.
However, I don't
think the
effect is that impressive
where I can say it's worth $25.
I was very intrigued by this KVD Beauty
ModCon Liquid-Gel Blush,
just because of the term "Liquid-Gel."
The texture of this is very bizarre.
It's very thin, and it feels like nothing.
I can't even explain it well.
But I was nervous to
put this on foundation,
because I felt like it
was going to break it up.
It didn't. I actually liked this way more
than I thought I was going to,
but it is a little sheer for me.
I did end up adding more,
but the problem when you do that is that
it adds more shininess,
which I didn't love,
but I don't hate this.
I'm gonna say that $26
for it feels excessive.
NYX came out with this Lip Lingerie XXL
Matte Liquid Lipstick,
which reminded me a lot of its
Shine Loud High Shine Lip Color,
only without the gloss.
NYX, please shorten your product names.
It's basically that,
but just a more matte liquid lipstick.
I'm a fully converted gloss girl now,
so applying a liquid lipstick
did have me stressed out,
but the formula is actually pretty nice.
I did one thin layer,
which I think is key
for products like this
because I find that
they do not layer well,
but one layer was all I
needed for full coverage.
I ate,
I drank,
and I wore this lipstick
for over eight hours,
and it stayed looking good.
It's pretty transfer-proof.
I did see some fading on
the inside of my mouth,
but overall I think this is great,
for people who are into
this sort of thing.
I was so excited for this
Maybelline Fit Me Tinted Moisturizer,
because I love the Fit Me line
and skin tints are so popular right now,
but this sucked so bad.
I'm so disappointed.
Off of the face, the texture honestly
felt really nice and hydrating.
But then I started applying,
and it dried down so quickly,
I couldn't blend it in.
I was beating my own face with my sponge,
trying to get it to move, and it didn't.
I completely removed it
and reapplied it again,
but it still was not the
most flattering on my skin.
I just think it made my texture worse
and also caked up in some areas
and overall just looked very not good.
Don't buy this one.
Next, we have the Givenchy
Prisme Libre Loose Powder.
I feel like I said that in Spanish,
but it's supposed to be French.
I'm going to start off by saying
I really liked this,
but that is not me saying
you need a $58 setting powder.
I'm just saying if you were looking
for a $58 setting powder,
I would get this one.
The multicolored powder thing looks cool,
but they all kind of blend into
one pretty translucent shade.
I think this actually did a nice job
of smoothing out my pores,
and it set my makeup
without making me feel dry.
I did feel like there was
some illuminating effect,
which is what I think
the green and purple powders are for.
But this has a very perfumy
smell, which I hate.
I choked several times.
Let's ban scents in
makeup. Thank you so much.
And, lastly, we have another weird blush.
This is the Bite Beauty
Daycation Whipped Cream Blush.
I feel like the worst part
about this blush is the packaging.
It's so hard to get any product out,
and when you do, it
just kind of shoots out,
so you get so much product
and kind of waste it.
But I do like the texture.
It's kind of mousse-y,
and the color of the blush
itself is very pretty.
It's glowy, but I feel like
it's a little too metallic
for it to look like natural dewiness,
if that makes any sense.
I do feel like the metallicness
enhanced my texture a bit,
but it wasn't too bad.
I just think that for $32,
I've tried better liquid-blush formulas.
But you can actually use this on the eyes,
and I like it more as
kind of a cream shadow
than I do as a blush.